You could run from danger,
but you can't run away from your feet.
She was one third of the iconic sitcom
trio in Three's Company
for more than five decades.
Suzanne Somers
entertained fans in front of the camera
while becoming a business mogul
behind the scenes.
If you believe in yourself and you focus
and you're willing to work like a dog,
you can make your dreams come true.
After more than a decade
stuck in bit roles,
Somers
landed a lead character in the 1977
sitcom Three's Company.
Playing
naive blond bombshell Chrissy Snow.
Three's Company became a ratings
bonanza and Somers
a merchandizing sensation.
In 1979.
She received a Golden Globe nomination
during the show's fifth season in 1980
summers as producers for equal pay
the same as her male costars.
I said
that's not going to get rid of Chrissy.
Never think
that you are you are not replaceable.
Her request for equal pay
she said got her fired.
I went from being the number one
actress on television
in those desired demographics
to now I couldn't get an interview.
Looking to reinvent herself,
Summers turned to her musical talent
to come back to the table.
In 1981, she opened a headlining show
in Las Vegas,
for which she won Las Vegas.
Female Entertainer of the year in 1986.
Her 1983 TV music special Suzanne
Somers and 10,000
guys earned her an Emmy nomination
for the top ten.
She returned to network TV in the late
eighties most notably
playing the mom in the 1991 family
sitcom step by step.
Later in life
she launched a talk
show on Lifetime in 2012.
Welcome to the Suzanne Show.
The Suzanne show earned her
a Daytime Emmy nomination.
Three years later
she appeared as a contestant
on Dancing with the Stars.
Off screen, Summers
became a bestselling author
while also
creating a fitness, health
and anti-aging empire in the nineties.
Her thigh master infomercial
also netted more
than $100 million in sales.
Then came a jewelry line
on the Home Shopping Network,
skincare, cosmetics and fashion.
In all over
500 products branded under her name.
Her books on alternative medicine
earned her a following
and plenty of criticism.
As a health guru and a qualified doctor,
Summers face several health
issues of her own
skin cancer in her thirties
and breast cancer in 2000 again in 2023.
But she's best known for her
vibrant legacy on screen and off.
If you just follow the flow of
your life and
and be
honest about it
you can make your life
anything you want it to be.